vous merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors le ramadan est terminée
quelle est l'atmosphère dans votre pays
bien l'atmosphère est assez tendue
encore parce que la situation sanitaire
ne s'est pas réellement amélioré avec
cette semaine de confinement et on
entame le déconfinement lundi il y aura
une reprise réouverture des cafés des
restaurants il y aura une reprise des
déplacements entre les gouvernorats
retour à l'école retour au lycée retour
des universités et donc c'est c'est une
ambiance assez assez calme il n'y a pas
une prise de conscience réelle de
dangerosité de l'épidémie et de cette
troisième vague
pour l'instant on a pris des mesures
cette semaine
vraiment cette semaine c'est ont été
confinés où c'était un confinement réel
avant pendant le reste du mois du
ramadan les cafés étaient ouverts les
restaurants étaient ouverts il y avait
juste un couvre feu à 22 heures et donc
c'est vraiment une semaine
effectif de confinement qui a eu lieu
alors les tunisiens vont fêter donc
l'aïd de manière confiné comment cela se
passe oui c'est aujourd'hui l'aïd c'est
aujourd'hui en les tunisiens vont fêter
ce mois
ce cette journée confiné les traditions
il ya beaucoup de déplacements entre les
gouvernorats justement l'étudiant vous
revoir l'ensemble de leurs familles des
fois ils se rassemblent pour déjeuner ou
pour dîner mais mais il ya beaucoup de
déplacements souvent des embouteillages
et c'est ce que le gouvernement essaie
de prévenir en en confinant justement
cette semaine la semaine de l'aïd ou au
coude et de tuer beaucoup de choses
rentrent chez eux rentrent chez leurs
familles et ils allaient donc on début
de semaine le gouvernement a annoncé
l'interdiction de déplacement entre
gouvernorat il a annoncé ce confinement
pour prévenir d'une heure d'un éventuel
irid qui peut
qui peut aggraver cette troisième vague
est ce que vous craignez par exemple
qu'un scénario à l'indian on sait que ce
sera compliqué d'y parvenir parce que la
situation est gravissime la barre mais
avec beaucoup de rassemblement religieux
en inde c'est ce qui a aussi favorisé la
propagation du virus du variant indien
la situation aujourd'hui en tunisie dans
beaucoup de pays arabes
vous pensez qu'on va respecter les
règles de les restrictions pour être
honnête je pense que dans une majorité
des dents une majorité du pays
les règles nous ne serons pas beaucoup
respecté il y aura en tout cas de
confinement il sera au moins qu'ici une
conscience générale du danger et même si
les règles sont les règles les plus
strictes ne sont pas appliquées au moins
1 un peu un tout petit peu de règles
sont appliquées c'est à dire les gestes
barrières et les masques sont cependant
moins appliqués mais je ne pense pas que
c'est comparable scénario indien même si
la surcharge de l'hôpital public est
réel là on la tunisie un énorme
déséquilibre entre en fait son armada
médicale publique et son armada de privé
où il ya énormément de moyens et de
l'autre côté dans le public il ya très
très peu de liens on parle de nous on
parle de en dehors des grandes villes en
parle d'une dizaine de lits disponibles
dans les régions intérieures c'est à
dire que c'est d'un c'est un scénario
qui semble lunaire quand on le voit dans
du point de vue des pays développés mais
le risque le risque est réel en tunisie
pour une surcharge de l'hôpital public
sauf si le gouvernement décide de
réquisitionner les les cliniques
recquise les réquisitionner le privé
pour en k2 en cas d'aggravation de la
situation et ça peut être une piste
envisagée pour le gouvernement
l'allègement des restrictions à venir
avec le cette troisième vague 90 morts
par jour en tunisie
et puis à la saison touristique qui
approche aussi donc le gouvernement doit
faire des choix ce que vous êtes inquiet
sur le sur la situation à venir dans
votre pays oui personnellement je suis
inquiet parce qu'à une mise en
opposition de l'économie et de la santé
c'est à dire que c'est une si tu ne
viens triste période que l'on vient
parce que en réalité il ya une pression
énorme sur l'économie tunisienne sur le
gouvernement parce que le chômage a
quasiment doublé l'année dernière il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de lieux de commerce
qui ont fermé il ya beaucoup de deux pme
qui en dut qui ont dû fermer également
donc il ya une pression économique qui
est réel et par contre tout ce qui est
saison touristique à mon avis c'est une
c'est une erreur fondamentale que fait
le gouvernement qui l'a déjà fait
l'année dernière quand on était à 0 k et
quand ils ont rouvert les frontières ils
ont promis une saison touristique est en
réalité il ya eu 80 % d'annulations et
eu quasiment personne donc donc je ne
pense pas que ce soit la solution
mais la position actuelle d'allègement
et compréhensible au vu de la situation
sociale qui est électrique c'est à dire
que le risque de désobéissance civile
cette semaine étaient réels c'est à dire
que donc plein de régions on a il ya eu
des manifestations de 2,2 de transport
de type d'accident eu des manifestations
de propriétaires de cafés et de
restaurants
c'est à dire que le risque de
désobéissance civile est grandissant
donc cet allègement et finalement
compréhensible d'un point de vue d'un
point de vue social merci beaucoup à
vous avez un souci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
essayiste